oh he's decided the vans picked him off
and he dropped it at 30 miles an hour
[Music]
hello i'm paddy mcginnis these two are
insignificant
and this is your driving fails
got a wrap on it so hold on wait there
we've got our lamborghini crash
correspondent we'll now take over the
voiceover
i i think we can stop though someone's
got a wrap lamborghini
next that's where you've gone wrong next
clip what's he doing he's getting out in
traffic because he's oh this one
this one's an absolute whopper look at
him absolutely
whopping he's just cracked his own
windscreen look he's just jumped onto
his windscreen and cracked it
yes what a tit god do you know what's
nice about this
what are you looking about rogue one
because he's got a lamborghini he might
be a nice guy
no he's not he's not teddy he's not he's
not
gareth southgate's himself here we are
deliberate what's going on in the
background
priests oh no he's let his prius go oh
he's got an unman
oh he's had of horror we've all done it
though lads we've all left the handbrake
off haven't we
i don't know if he's left the ambree
coffee i've left a fan break off before
what were you in uh it was a porsche 911
when i got back
no it just rolled across the car park
and taken up two spaces and everyone
thought i'd parked it badly
that's right that's what you tell he's
putting it out there i know because he
did park it badly
i love this bud that looks like your
profile when you're sitting in the car
here we are what's he doing
he's going oh he's going on top road
[Laughter]
he's batched it that's forgivable that
then many people have done that in the
services haven't they just gone forward
you reached it
oh i love this is a bike he's gotta
write a bike usually this camera is on
the wrong side of the road what is
what's he doing there's a car coming
here well he's parked cars though chris
oh it's a one-way street this one oh oh
oh oh hello and there's some masters
i'm not sure that's that funny you're
basically just showing us a
an rca couple of clios so it's clearly a
renault specialist
[Music]
and this is when you pull them up on the
goal it was loud when you brought it in
there yeah
push box push pull personalised number
plate could be fred when he was younger
no it's not blue oh he's he's decided
the vans picked him off
and he dropped it at 30 miles an hour
trouble is he's done well though because
i didn't get the full 360.
i got a bit of a 180 now that was a
shambolic piece of driving
you